Pera you're not supposed to be in the
intro finally got this machine work
there's some tricky puzzles very tricky
puzzles but I use my Russian engineering
spell skills in Soviet Russia it was
engineer
Alice Bailey stabbed targets are
[ __ ] all right a lot of [ __ ] you had
to do a lot of [ __ ] wait I forgot
something
I forgot that I should open the door
actually I got the machinery working bag
I got a new door I gotta open Oh hope
you bros haven't forgot about the
livestream I'm planning to play barrels
you're not supposed to be in the
lifestream barrels a lot of amnesia and
some other stuff
why aren't you working thank you very
much thank you very much All Right see
you later Machinery keep doing what
you're doing
I'll just put my penis in there and back
that was hard now I know why I said that
barrel I'll put your penis in there
maybe okay anyway the livestream is 8
p.m. GMT plus one it's gonna I'm gonna
upload a video on YouTube saying that
I'm gonna livestream and it probably
gonna be up very now my tal search you
nearly distracted me for my italicized
brush barrel barrel
oh wait okay
da ba ya
Oh nice protection bro Wow I did really
good god damn it I keep swearing in
Swedish stupid Swedish commentaries
turning me into a Swedish person I am
speech
okay
[Music]
it does not work what about now check it
out now the funk soul brother brother
shaft man there we go
it's back up you can get the [ __ ] out of
now thank you very much alright we can't
go there so we go here equipment
hello anybody in here can I move this
mice John Hyde
I want to try to hide I don't appreciate
especially when it doesn't break unless
pity your fake stop picked up a rusty
key I think this is it and then we go to
the basement I don't really want to go
to the basement - quiet on it bad stuff
happens in the basement oh no is it
water it's oh it's cold it's [ __ ]
cold too
come on alright there's nothing back
here another door okay
hi just raising food but oh it's four
chefs still a freaking water monster
here I know it
what is this place anyway
any sharks anything I don't like that
no sir no sir I don't like this one
[ __ ] bet I hate that [ __ ] monster
so we need to get up there maybe I don't
know they had a thing like that before
and then watching nothing much we'll try
it just for walls just Sullivan third
portal a lot of us see see okay my
talent is not very good I will build the
best [ __ ] box thing in the entire
freakin way come on bats quatrain stop
stop right there box okay thank you
how do I do this
I'm almost there come on don't [ __ ]
things up for me just cause you're a box
I don't think this this is awry let's
see if I can get my head up there I
can't jump god [ __ ] damn it no I
don't think there's anything there's a
[ __ ] lamp there alright listen check
this out first
hello any water monster way Oh booth the
book
what's going on here oh no it's like
dead people I don't like when they're
dead thank you I prefer them that I'm
just kidding all right let's go here I'm
so confused right now I'm so freakin
fused
uh okay open the door open the door
burner huh
open the [ __ ] dude this coming for me
it's coming for me yeah yeah I have a
ladder oh that's what I needed it for a
nurse toddlers in a place like this
I love toilet hello leg happy day I'm a
big fan i watch your show love your
amnesia view huh does this mean I mean
yeah I always want to be honorary out
sorry but you will become food of this
freaking water monster in it are your
star [ __ ] useless aren't you Oh
where's that little [ __ ] where is this
stuck oh I don't even know anymore I
don't even [ __ ] know I have a box
that's what [ __ ] so much interpretive
Lucifer's I can't aha hi Rob ah man dad
it hurts it bite me my [ __ ] butt well
I don't have [ __ ]
Oh oh snap snappy soon savvy soon huh oh
my god my pan ah you're not supposed to
be in here
okay now yes yes
hey it's kind of cozy here why are we
supposed to do with you
you're just here nothing else but I'm
just gonna drop it in the water I don't
like that no no this is not what I
wanted this is not what I wanted at all
I'm just gonna drop this [ __ ] Spang
now come on all right
what spot the PD I'm not a soldier but I
know it okay it's gonna put you don't
you dare fall in the water
hello mister water monster I don't even
know where to put this [ __ ] thing I
know we have our differences
no no don't drop it that was the first
[ __ ] real pity all right one
Worcester I know we have our differences
but sometimes you just gotta say [ __ ] it
I don't want to hate down this guy he
hasn't done me anything we should just
all get along in hug I would love a hug
not from you probably it's probably
[ __ ] perhaps here all right let's
just ah [ __ ] it I'll if I lose this
thing my life is all there disgusting
this [ __ ] place going down here can I
walk through this no Porter
too fat got a diet
saying here I didn't check for doors of
course not let's check the door since
the water monsters in here
I want my toddlers give me my toddler's
answers and it's my dancers Oh tryin
very well we shall go with this level
here and see what we can penetrate it we
must penetrate all of our lower in I
don't even know what I'm talking about I
don't think we need to go back ah what
am I supposed to judge this [ __ ]
lever I'll ever understand life will
never be the same
wait oh I know we needed in school but I
spent half my life I know I seen where
this okay
everyone build it it solve it no it's
not obvious it's up it's okay
I can start waiting my ladder but I I'll
be damned to shave it's obvious all
right penetrate that [ __ ] on you see
that jump penetration have you ever seen
that before
no you haven't you know why box get that
affair I remember I'm specifically there
was a better place upon you Oh No
why did he even win from this we want a
[ __ ] pipe well would be [ __ ] there
I don't even know anymore
oh I remember now yes we needed that
pipe we needed it so much I love pipes
big fan of pipes I like them on Facebook
oh thank God I thought it was oh I hate
that [ __ ] water monster okay so we'll
just put the pipe where it belong and
then there I can go home and eat some
Hot Pocket I love hot cabbage they don't
have them in Sweden with may be imagined
they're delicious because they look like
bacon deliciousness but you're right
there buddy
and you'll just slide right up
yeah thank you thank you now how does
one simply oh okay I see it
ah god damn I'm so fat no I just to have
it oh I did it
oh please long
oh well bleep blond love to see after he
lied on the hell is this place which
store should I pick what does this say
to ulstad in this one entrance well [ __ ]
that I'm going to out stretch maybe we
can meet Boris you mustn't leave our god
[ __ ] I knew it so obvious oh well
what can you do I'm just demand a man
with a quest I don't think we have much
I have some business to do I don't even
know what the business was sorry
all right fine it's a casual pretty cozy
so question is where bad things happened
probably yes
I'm dizzy I ran over oil first bad thing
that happen what the hell is this that's
some weird [ __ ] map design I kind of
like it though okay what that all right
let's go here then ash boat I don't
trust anything you try to blend in with
the background these days I don't get
that of here all right
stupid nights don't even know what
they're doing anymore why would they
know Oh
push push it to the limit yes break that
[ __ ] yes they don't call me he-man for
nothing
all rights go in here castle
I'm saying alright I'm actually gonna
end it here cuz you know stuff I'm like
I said I'm gonna do a livestream link in
description for life she also linked to
the voting whatever which doors they
choose actually I was gonna any please
check the link inscription for the vote
thing we're catching up to become a
first place but I need your help to vote
every day I really appreciate it I'm
gonna donate all the prize money to
charities anyway that's pretty much it
like
[Music]